The first one is d. The second one is b. The third one is a. And the fourth one
is c. Using equals instead of equals equals or .equals is an easy mistake to
make. This won't compile. If I create a string friends, and set it equal to the
empty string. And now, if friends is the empty screen. And I'm going to use
Shift Enter to go down a line without running it. Then I'll print out no
friends left. Now if I run this, I get an error incompatible types, because
friends equals the empty string, isn't a condition. It can't go inside of an if
check. In the second one, friends will never be null. No matter how many
friends we remove we just erase their names from the string, we don't reset the
string to be null. In this third one, we're comparing using equals, equals. But
strings are objects so we always want to use dot equals to compare them. In
this last one, we say if the number of friends equals, equals the number of
people times 0.33. Then you're friends with one in three people. But these are
doubles, and doubles have precision loss. So, you could actually find out that
numFriends equals numPeople times 0.33333 or 0.339, or something like that, and
this wouldn't be true. Even though that person is basically friends with one in
three people. When comparing doubles, you always want to find the difference
between them, and then compare it to a threshold. Pick an epsilon, that is the
biggest difference you want to accept, and compare the actual difference with
your epsilon.